can i ask you after you've written that
heading just to have a look at
everything that we have just done okay
what we've been doing is differentiating
a variety of different functions and
then we looked at
chain rule we looked at product rule i
didn't make you do question rule because
question rules i mean it's just a bit
gross to be honest so but you know it
right you've encountered this before
okay
however just having a look at the
questions you've used
general
product rule and quotient rule
all on the same kinds of functions these
all share the same kind of dna they're
all x to the power of something yeah do
you see that
so we call this big family mostly we
call them polynomials right they're
powers they're pretty easy to deal with
okay
but last year we got introduced to these
that's why it was question six here
right we got introduced to them but we
just kind of stayed on really simple
ones i mean
kind of this guy right and we didn't
stray very far from that
but i want to do that today and over the
next couple of weeks right we're going
to expand out on the kinds of things
that we did with polynomials we're going
to do them with exponentials i remember
yesterday i asked you this question like
why should you care okay and i always
want to try and answer that question
every lesson and so should you even if
the teacher doesn't tell you you should
be asking that question
so i want you to write this down and
then you're also going to need your
devices for this in a second if you
haven't got them out already so maybe
get them out now
we're going to consider
a particular exponential function
and hopefully it will remind you of why
we care about this here's the function
y equals
okay now the reason i'm asking you to
get your laptops out is because i'd like
you to go to desmos
desmos.com calculator which i'm sure
you've you guys have played a bit with
desmos before can you give me a show of
hands if you've like yeah you've used it
fantastic thank you for hands down
i want you to go open it
and then this is what i'd like you to
plot now just as a minor minor thing
which will help you use desmos more
helpfully if i read this out right it is
6 divided by
1
plus e to the power of 5 minus x
desmos will be happier with you if you
try to put a bracket here it'll
automatically put one on the end for you
right just trying to do your favor if
you type something else it'll give you
something rather different okay
now some of you will get there before
others and that's fine with me
eventually we'll all get there
once
someone gets there can someone tell me
what the significance of this shape is
you would need to have been here
yesterday probably um and
hopefully that will give you enough of a
clue maybe before you even graph it
you'll recognize it
anyone want to tell me what the
significance of this thing is
have you got the shape yeah go ahead
fantastic so this graph here it's this
uh it's this weird kind of curvy thing
looking here right if we typed it right
anyway it is this thing which closely
models what's happening with case
numbers for actually any disease it's
not just covert right this thing has a
name i'd love you to jot it down with me
it is called
the logistic
model
now hopefully you can see that it shares
something in common with things you know
about right it's got this e to the this
kind of an x in there right
but if i handed this to you
even though this looks very easy to
differentiate uh
where do i even start with this thing
it's a bit of a mess okay now by the
time we're done with this we'll be able
to understand how to differentiate this
and how to tease it apart okay we're
actually going to use the same bag of
tricks that you learnt with all of this
stuff right so i'm going to give you a
simple example that we can do together
so here comes example one
we're going to differentiate y equals
e to the power of
x cubed plus 1.
now
i'm not going to call on you to give me
an answer aloud but i just do want to
get an indication who reckons at this
moment they could differentiate this
right now any takers
because some might have encountered it
okay no problem that's right
that's why we're teaching you so here's
what we're going to do i chose xqboss1
quite deliberately do you recognize it
uh you did it like 10 minutes ago okay
so this actually shares a lot in common
with this question here
this e to the power of stuff right this
is a function e to the power of stuff of
a
another function that's why i
highlighted this name before right so
therefore i can treat this the same way
i treated this i can use exactly the
same technique okay to make it a little
more obvious we're going to write a bit
of working underneath here to clarify
what's going on so to give this
a name as it were okay i'm going to say
let
well i need to choose a name for this
like this is you know uh lost it f x or
f of t that's like a name for the
function okay so i'm going to call it
u
uh in much the same way that we were
doing you with where the product will go
here right here right
so i'm going to say let's call this
thing up here
u equals
x cubed plus one
i'm just going to introduce this new
letter which seems like it's making
things more complicated but watch how
much simpler it makes things
if you
is just going to swap out for this i can
write that y equals
e
to the power of just
u is that okay like i'm just just a a
quick substitution so this is e
to the power of u
now the reason why this is nice is
because
i already know how to differentiate this
you just i mean you don't even have to
do anything right the only weirdness is
the letters are a bit different
i had a d y on dx down here
this is not going to be a d y on dx
there's no x's at all
instead it's going to be d y on
d u that's the only other letter to use
right so
d u ah that's a bit sneaky e is kind of
masquerading as a letter at the moment
it's really a number isn't it okay
so
we just saw this is the thing which when
you differentiate it nothing happens so
its derivative will just be e
to the u
that's it right that's the thing that we
love about differentiating exponentials
they're really good for lazy people
which all mathematicians are
now have a look over here right this is
also something i know how to
differentiate right except it's not d y
on dx there's no y here
it's going to be something else on dx
what is that
fantastic nice one josh so this is d u
on dx you see why remember i told you
before like sometimes we see this um
this dash notation and it's really good
to use it's very quick it's it's
succinct but there's a lot that's
missing when you just write a dash
you're like what letters are we talking
about here
this thing you've already differentiated
today right what did you get when you
did it before
three
x squared right
you're like this is too easy is it a
trick question i don't know okay so now
that you've got all these pieces i don't
know if you can tell i'm smiling under
this but anyway um now that you've got
all these pieces i can take this jigsaw
puzzle and this jigsaw puzzle and jam
them together watch what happens
when you take these two things together
d y on d u
that's the one on the right hand side
and if you multiply it by d u
on
dx what do you think will happen
just look at the fractions right yeah
josh
will cancel each other out those two
guys there on the numerator on the
denominator they'll cancel out just like
every other fraction you've kind of
dealt with right so in fact i'll just
put this in dot lines
because i've got the same thing on this
denominator as i have in this numerator
what i get left behind is
the thing that i wanted d y
on dx you see how this works okay that's
the thing that i was after in the first
place so
let's just put them together i guess
what did we say dyan do you was again
it's on the board it's on the board
e to the power of u so i'll just jot
that down
what did we work out d u on dx was
squared so i'll just multiply there
and at this point i'm pretty much
finished the only thing i need to do is
we introduced this letter u remember
that it's like just just so that we
could make it a bit easier for ourselves
all this red working we kind of did just
to make it a little bit simpler but the
question never had any use in it to
begin with right so i should probably
put it back the way it was i'll put that
u
back to being
what i defined it to be x cubed plus one
so let's write that like so
uh e
to the power of x cubed plus one
and then i'm multiplying by three
x squared i mean if you wanted to you
could write it the other way around
because products
the order doesn't really matter some of
you might feel like that's a teeny bit
simpler but they really are
the same thing
does that make sense are you content
with that